okay
take a breath well done we are now on to
part two hopefully you got that
somewhere there on screen we need to
we're required to prove um this weird
looking result i'm going to talk about
it in a second to give you that same
nudge that i gave you before okay here's
what we were required to prove i n
equals
oh my goodness 2 to the 2 n on its n
factorial squared
all divided by
2 n plus 1 factorial
where do i even start there's this scene
in the movie inception i don't know how
many of you guys have seen the movie
inception leno dicaprio
and a bunch of other people joseph
gordon-levitt
there's a scene in the movie where uh
leonardo dicaprio the main character
he's talking to another person who's
realizing that he's not awake he's in a
dream and he starts to panic and
leonardo dicaprio says to him don't
panic i know this looks terrible and
you're frightened but remember your
training and you'll be able to get
through this and that's exactly what i
want to say to you here is you look at
this hilariously awkward result that you
have to prove don't panic don't be
intimidated by how awful this looks
remember your training you actually know
enough to deal with this
it looks weird because it's a strange
looking expression fraction and there's
these with factorials in there like how
did they even arrive but i want you to
consider two things like what's being
asked of you here right
number one we are trying to express i n
without any integrals on the right hand
side now if you just ignored this right
like just imagine it wasn't there okay
it was i n and then on the right hand
side you've just got stuff without
integrals
whatever they are that always means
we're going to try and go from our
recurrence relation and step down down
down down down the ladder until we get
to a point where we can actually
evaluate one of those integrals and then
you have no integrals left so therefore
you can say oh it's equal to this and
it's an expression it's a formula that
is independent of calculus so we've done
this a bunch of times before even though
this looks terrible um we can still do
it okay we're going to have to step down
through the ladder like we've done many
times before
the second thing that is worth pointing
out is that actually even though
factorials are weird you're like this is
not perms and columns where i normally
see factorials we shouldn't be that
surprised that a factorial will appear
in a recurrence relation
because factorials themselves
are recurrence relations aren't they
think about this right
what is the definition whoops what is
the definition of n factorial isn't it
n times
n minus 1 and you keep on climbing down
until you get to 1 in other words it's n
minus 1 factorial can you see that you
can use
the sort of recurrence relation notation
that we've been using
already like call it f for factorial
it's clearly n times f
n minus 1. there it is recurrence
relation so actually low-key recurrence
relations turn up with or they result in
factorials a lot more than you would
think it's just that we don't always go
to the actual working okay so we
shouldn't be that surprised that a
factor appears is my point
okay so here's what i'm going to do i'm
going to give you that same nudge
i'm not going to give you heaps of time
sorry this is taking longer than i
thought that's i can blame some people
in their wonderful singing expertise for
that so um
i i'm going to do it i'm going to give
you the nudge to get towards this
particular result but i'm not going to
let i'm not going to finish it here i'm
going to give you some time to give it a
go
so here's my nudge
from part one right that result that we
just proved
i've got this right here it is part one
and i can use this result to step down
the ladder i can just look and see what
happens as i go down to the n minus 1
step right by substituting in n minus 1
to everywhere that i saw n
on this line of the formula so what
happens well if you think about this
you're going to get
2 times n minus 1 on the top and then on
the denominator um you're going to get
that same thing to n minus one but
you're adding one yeah and then one step
down now
i'm seeking to establish a pattern right
so therefore i'm going to expand what
you can see here on the numerator and
the denominator because i think it'll
make the pattern more obvious on the
numerator you're going to get 2n minus 2
and because the denominator is just one
bigger 2n plus 1 then the numerator i
can just go straight to like i don't
even think about the expansion right
it's going to be 2n
minus 1.
that's one bigger than the numerator
right and then the iron minus 2 is there
you want to make a pattern in ap or a gp
or anything you need a third term right
so let's just go to i n minus two and
hopefully you're seeing the pattern here
right maybe you can even expand at the
same time when you put in n minus two
into here you get two n minus four on
the top and the denominator is just one
bigger than that two n minus three and
then it goes to the next step so look
carefully right
from this numerator to this numerator to
this numerator
it's decreasing by two of course it is
because you're multiplying that whole
numerator by two so as you step down one
at a time you're going in steps of two
and the denominator is doing much the
same thing it goes from two n plus one
to two n minus one to two n minus 3. of
course it's going at the same rate
because it's the same as the numerator
but one bigger okay
so
we need to know this is where the series
or the product rather series is a sum
these things being multiplied this is
where the product begins we need to know
where the product where these terms end
up where can i step off the ladder of
the recurrence relation to actually
evaluate one of these integrals okay so
i'm going to say over to you can you
work out where this
this term these terms um this big long
product where do they end and then can
you put that all together to come up
with the result they want us to prove in
part two
i'm trying to determine where these n
these terms end which like i said means
that we've got to get through these i n
i n minus 1 terms etc until i land on
something i can integrate quite
comfortably so let me just go back to
what the original integral looks like
ta-da there it is right
there's i am okay so i need to choose
some value of n then i'm like yeah i
feel comfortable integrating that like i
can do this result and i can just work
out a number out of this now
we know that we're going to have to go a
fair way along
so we go from n to n minus 1 n minus 2
etc a factorial ends at 1 right like the
last terms is like times 3 times 2 times
1. so n equals 1 is not a bad like
thought often recurrence relations once
you get to n equals 1 you can evaluate
but when you look at it very quickly
when you put n equals 1 into here what
do you get
sine
cubed
of 2 theta d theta
no thanks right so therefore even though
i can work out i 1 in a second i think
i'm going to need to go one more step
after that which is zero not all
recurrence relations are defined for n
equals zero um in fact you can see here
you've got like this thing this i n says
hey n is greater than or equal to one
but then i want you to go back and see
the original one here it's defined for
zero the reason why this n is greater
than or equal to one is applied is
because there's an i n minus one there
so if you put zero into this expression
or this equation rather you'd get an i
of negative one that's not allowed but
this one can go all the way down to zero
so that's where i'm going to head
let's go ahead and evaluate i
zero it's going to be the integral from
naught to pi on two of
sine okay here comes the two times zero
which is zero plus one so that's just
one
sine of two theta
d theta that's a relief this i know how
to integrate in fact i already
integrated this exact thing back when i
do integration by parts this is going to
be negative a half of cos 2 theta
and here are my boundaries not to pi on
2.
hopefully this is fairly routine at this
point if you pull out your negative a
half you're gonna be evaluating cos pi
and cos zero i think you guys can handle
that by the time you get through those
lines of working i hope you land on one
all that work for one okay yes that's
fine
that's exactly where you end but for
reasons they're going to become clear
for a second i'm going to also need like
a little bit before that so that i can
see fully where this pattern is is
looking at and how i can identify bits
of it that are useful for me to prove
the result i've been asked so i'm going
to go i
1. so before i climb down the ladder
from the top from n n minus one n minus
two et cetera here i've started the
bottom and i'm just sort of climbing up
just a teeny bit so i can see where this
thing finishes okay
as you saw right before again from part
one here's our definition for i n so if
my i n minus one is going to be i zero
because i know what that's equal to then
i'm choosing n equals one on the left
hand side here right so it's going to be
i one equals two oops it does see 2n
which in this case is 2 over
2n plus 1 so that's 2 plus 1 and then i
multiply by i naught so i'm getting 2 3
times 1
which is 2 3.